I first heard about it on the BBC news
going home and five o'clock news and
they talked about this new discovery
which is going to change the world of
particle physics and how we understand
the universe and I'm going on and they
talked about the how the electron is a
perfect sphere and I'm thinking well
what experiment is this is and gradually
as they talked a little bit more I
realized it's I knew what the experiment
was and I even know the people who have
done it and there were my colleagues in
Sussex and so I know Johnny Hudson and
Ed Hines very well in Ben sour and so it
was really great to hear about the
experiment I've never thought about it
as being the electron is a sphere I
thought about is the electron dipole
moment somehow I don't think if they'd
have talked about the electric dipole
moment of the electron that might not
have made the BBC News
the heavy experimental details because
it's too complicated for a theorist like
myself but I can tell you some of the
background first of all why I say the
electron is a sphere when we we think of
the electron as actually as a
fundamental particle it's one of the
building blocks of the standard model
and normally you think of that as a
point like object so what does it mean
to say it's a sphere and I think what
they're really talking about is the
charge the electrons got a charge an
electric charge and they're talking
about the distribution of that charge
they've measured it to be almost
spherical and in fact to show the
precision of their experiment they've
demonstrated that that distribution if
if they could scale it up to the size of
the solar system then it would be a
sphere to within a hair's breadth they
could measure a deviation of a hair's
width so a sphere the size of the solar
system they could measure a deviation of
that charge distribution of a hair's
width it turns out that the that
distribution of the charge around the
electron is really important in
understanding the nature of the matter
antimatter is symmetry the fact that we
live in a universe made up mainly of
matter very little antimatter around and
yet we believe in the early universe
they were created in equal amounts so
what has happened and the by finding
this a deviation of this charge from
this perfectly spherical charge you we
would hopefully gain some information
about this origin of this matter
antimatter asymmetry so let me step back
before I go into those details and
perhaps just talk a little bit about the
what it means to be not spherical so so
a spherical distribution of charge
basically the way I think about it
anyway is that if you happen to have a
detector that could pick up charge could
measure charge then if my electron is
here then the detector would pick up an
equal amount of charge on this side as
it would on this side as it would up and
down and all the way around it would be
perfectly spherical it wouldn't see any
preferential distribution of
that's called a monopole by the way
where it where it's equally distributed
like that a spherical distribution now
the next thing you can do you can if you
want to distort this charge is the next
simplest one is called a dipole and
we're used to dipoles at school were
used to dipoles magnetic dipoles a bow
magnet right as a South Pole in a North
Pole and we're used to that in magnetic
cases but it also exists in the electric
case if I had a positive electric charge
and a negative electric charge then the
dipole would be and put them close to
one another the dipole would be a line
that goes from the negative to the
positive charge right so this is the
electrons only got a negative charge so
it turns out that you don't have to have
a positive and a negative charge to have
a have a dipole you just need to have a
distribution of the charge which is not
spherical so if for example I distorted
this sphere so I made it so that maybe
more like a raindrop okay which has got
a bull a bulge ascend at one bit than an
arrow end at the other so there's more
charge over here and less charge over
here then I would have a dipole going
from from one one part to the other part
that's what they're looking for that's
what this experiment is looking for with
the electron they're looking for this
asymmetry in the charge and things that
cause this asymmetry at the interaction
of the electron with the other particles
now in the standard model of particle
physics the one that describes the
universe as well as we know it the we
there is an asymmetry
it's induced by the interaction between
the electrons and the quarks actually
but it's so small it's expected to be an
observable so the fact that it hasn't
been seen is no surprise but we know
that the standard model of particle
physics can't describe it doesn't
describe everything so there are extra
modifications called beyond the standard
model which people have put forward
there are lots of variants and one of
the goals of places like the LHC is to
test these models and what's wonderful
one of the wonderful things about this
experiment is
it's also testing these models but B
it's in a lab much lower energies just
in the lab down Imperial College with
their ed Heinz in his group and what
they're looking for then is the
interaction between some of these new
particles in particular supersymmetric
particles they're called
they're the partners of the particles
that we that we know exist they're
looking for the possible interaction
between those particles and the electron
and and the theories predict that in
some of those cases you expect them to
induce this sa symmetry and what they've
managed to demonstrate is through you
know months and months in fact years of
working on this is that there is no
asymmetry they've they've even though
they've got their sensitivity down down
and down and down the electron
distribution of the charge still seems
perfectly spherical they're seeing no
deviation that then means that those
models which predict there should be a
deviation that's already in excess of
what has been seen and ruled out it
doesn't rule out supersymmetry
supersymmetry is a vast subject and
there are lots of regions of parameters
in supersymmetry which you can still go
to which would be perfectly consistent
with the observation of no distortion
but it's severely constraining it what
the experiment is is so you've got to
create this dipole you've got you're
trying to test for this dipole moment
well basically put the electrons in it
in an electric field but if you were to
simply put an electron in an electric
field you've created a little
accelerator
it's your cathode ray tube it's your
television it shoots out and you've lost
it so what they do is they put they look
at molecules and molecules of e.u
terbium fluoride okay fluoride of
fluorine I've heard of incredibly
reactive apparently the ytterbium is
heavy and heavy at an atom of you
terbium is very heavy
we need Martin an atom of fluorine is
very light so it itself already has
remember I talked about the distribution
of the the electric it produces a net
electric dipole moment in it
right and so the electrons are already
enhanced by just being in the presence
of this these molecules so they put
these molecules in then the apply an
electric field that shifts the energy
level of the electrons then they switch
the electric field and the energy levels
shift again now the amount of shifting
of these in it of the energy of the
electrons actually depends upon the
dipole moment so the bigger the shift of
the electrons the bigger the dipole
moment so that's what they're looking
for they're looking to measure the shift
and they can double it up by reversing
the field so that it's goes from
positive to negative so it increases the
ridge and that's what they've been
looking for they've been they've been
looking for that shift and we've seen no
evidence of that shift in in their
analysis they have they look they have
all of these data all this data and of
course it's all done on a computer as
well as analyzing it all in the computer
so there is a box there or a screen
which will constantly be giving them the
electric dipole moment but they cover it
up right they've had it covered up
because they don't want to be influenced
by the by the kind as they're trying to
reduce all their errors they don't want
to sort of be influenced and have a
quick look and say oh if we just tweak
that a bit more we'll get this down and
and it's very important you do that that
you it must have been so difficult for
them not to go and have a quick peek to
see what they were seeing and what they
do is they eventually reach a stage
where they think that they've basically
accounted for everything they can
possibly account for over that you know
in the sensible time period and they
pulled the screen off they pull the the
cover off the screen and they look and I
saw it happens yesterday I was on a
panel with him and I asked him what it
was like and he said they pulled it off
they had a meeting they'd said is it
time first time around there was
disagreement people's thought they could
still work on a few more systematics and
eventually the group said yes let's do
it pulled it off so the result it was
there open a bottle of champagne and the
world got to hear about it